est ce qu'une langue donnée quand on la
parle peut propager le coronavirus plus
efficacement qu'une autre la réponse va
vous surprendre les mots transmettent
bien des choses
des idées des sentiments des opinions et
das
ils transmettent aussi des virus alors
certains mots sont ils plus dangereux
que d'autres
un chasseur sachant chasser doit savoir
chasser sans son chien quand on parle il
n'y a pas que des sons qui sortent mais
aussi des postillons
on ne postillonne pas de la même façon
dans toutes les langues mais pour
comprendre comment chaque langue peut
propager le virus
il faut d'abord revenir aux bases de la
politique
nous sommes à l'université de princeton
le chercheur out stone et son équipe ont
voulu comprendre comment se propage
l'air qui sort de notre bouche vous
produisez des gouttelettes en parlant et
le nombre de gouttelettes est différent
pour les voyelles et pour les consonnes
voici son équipement une machine à fumée
et un faisceau laser
ça lui permet d'observer en temps réel
le mouvement de l'air plusieurs des
phrases que vous dites contiennent des
plots ziv
c'est à dire des sons qui se forme dans
votre bouche avec une forte pression
d'air pendant un bref instant quand
cette pression et relâcher et se crée un
flux d'air très rapide devant vous cela
forme des régions conique où tous les
rex pire et se dirigent les plausibles
sont les consonnes pbt des cas et gars
pour certains sont comme le i le flux
d'air produit par notre bouche se dirige
vers le bas pour d'autres comme le haut
il monte mais pour les consonnes
plausible comme le plr se dirige tout
droit vers l'interlocuteur
cela sort dans un jet presque droit ce
puissant mouvement de vortex transporte
ensuite tout l'air avec lui nous avons
observé que l'air expiré avec une clause
yves peut voyager d'un mètre en une
seconde
leur expérience ne s'arrête pas là les
chercheurs ont aussi observé comment la
salive et expulsé de la bouche à la
milliseconde près surtout pour les
consoles plausible comme p -b
[Musique]
quand vos lèvres sont humides et que
vous les ouvrez pourparlers il se forme
un mince film de salive
ce film se brise ensuite rapidement en
petits filaments
quand vous parlez que vous expirez ces
filaments sont étirées par l'air puis il
se brise en petites gouttelettes grand
gros gras graindorge quand des grands
gros gras graindorge ratu puisque mes
lèvres ne se ferme pas il n'y a pas de
filaments qui se forment par contre si
je dis petit pot de beurre
quand des petits pots de beurre il auras
tu l'as j'expulse plus de gouttelettes
[Musique]
y at il des langues plus à risque que
d'autres
il n'y a pas beaucoup de recherches sur
la relation entre les virus et les
langues
alors nous avons décidé de faire cette
étude aux estables
ce linguiste basé à moscou s'est
intéressé au sujet il a comparé le taux
de transmission du virus avec la
fréquence d'utilisation des consoles
plausible pour 14 pays nous avons trouvé
une corrélation seulement pour le son p
ça cela veut dire que les noms qui
utilise plus le son pays ont plus de
risque de transmettre le virus
en tête du palmarès
le polonais et l'italien le français lui
se situe en quatrième place et
l'allemand est la langue la - aris mme
évidemment nous ne pouvons pas dire aux
gens de ne pas parler leur langue
cependant nous pouvons prendre en
considération le facteur linguistique
pour construire des modèles qui
prédisent la propagation de la pandémie
une chanson comme celle ci démontre
qu'on peut contaminer nos proches
même avec des mots d'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]